[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer at the observer sonia soda
and the chief political correspondent at
the daily telegraph christopher hope
great to see you both
as evan let's look at the front pages
shall we
the eye reporting on boris johnson's
announcement that there will be no more
covert restrictions this side of
christmas that's also the lead for the
metro with the headline christmas can go
ahead the telegraph says that while
christmas gatherings have been given the
green light more measures could be
introduced before new year
the guardian focuses on warnings that
the decision to delay any measures until
after christmas could result in tougher
restrictions in the new year same story
for the mirror which goes with the
headline christmas cheer and fear
the times leads on boris johnson's calls
for people to test before seeing family
this christmas
the delhi star makes light of the
current state of the pandemic with
children apparently asking santa for a
luxury box of lateral flow tests
meanwhile in scotland public hog money
celebrations have already been called
off after nicola sturgeon's decision to
cancel large event that makes the front
of the press and journal
and president putin has warned nato
against expanding eastwards towards the
russian border that's on the front of
the ft
so let's get the thoughts of sonja and
christopher and apart from the ft not
surprising really that uh the
announcements of which there were a
flurry today have made all of the front
pages uh sonia your thoughts first of
all um england no kerbs announced before
or after christmas and uh clearly we've
had something from nicholas sturgeon and
uh the uh the welsh are meeting again
tomorrow in the cabinet aren't they
yeah it's not the first time in this
pandemic that we've seen the approaches
of england and scotland diverge
and it seems that this time nicholas
sturgeon has taken a more cautious
approach so she's announced that new
year plans are off um that that sports
will be spectators from boxing day
boris johnson hasn't introduced any more
restrictions before christmas but is
reserving the right to do so afterwards
and he confirmed that today
and i think um there's a big sort of
question mark hanging over this which is
that we know that the growth in omega
crown cases has been incredibly fast
over the last week and a half but
actually the data from the last kind of
three or four days it's it's too early
to tell definitively but it suggests
that there may be a bit of plateauing in
the numbers and then the other key piece
of information is around hospitalization
rates and we've had new data about a
number of hospitalizations out from
london today and the figures are up but
maybe not up quite as much as some
scientists were fearing so i think all
of that added together it's it's very
difficult i think for politicians right
now because they are making decisions
based on imperfect data and you can see
i think why um why you might go down the
more cautious route that sturgeon has
with her advice for no more than three
households to mix before and after
christmas um or the sort of slightly
more lacks in boris johnson you can make
a case for either actually on the data
at the moment because there is so much
uncertainty and i think we've all got to
just hope that these sort of slightly
green shoots that we're seeing in the
data in the last day or so i mean it's
not looking great but it's no it's not
as bad as it could have been um i think
we just have to keep everything crossed
um that that those trends uh continue
and amid uh this resurgent pandemic
there is a celebratory heir from a
number of newspapers we saw the
telegraph there christopher your pa your
paper glad tidings for christmas perhaps
not new year the metro as well christmas
can go ahead with the exclamation mark
and again the eye christmas is happening
now the uk waits on london hospital data
is it is it too early to start
celebrating
christopher of course this is only in
england isn't it um well i i i've got
some sympathy for the cabinet on on um
on monday when only four of them
called for new restrictions and the rest
said well where is where are the figures
because they've got
the familiar drum beats we're going
towards a big uh lockdown or a degree of
lockdown in england going back to the
sage papers on saturday
saturday jammed on sunday on sky news
talking about how these are serious and
big warnings if mercedes and by monday i
think ministers said well listen where
is where is the actual numbers and we
aren't seeing anywhere near overwhelming
of hospitals deaths are not rising um
yes there are a lot of kobe cases and
yes there are a lot of omicron cases the
variant which is so infectious but
actually do we need to really rely on
these forecasts that be wrong in the
past and it may maybe just maybe that
boss johnson might get a christmas
miracle here and show the other
developed nations which are swiftly
bringing measures in scotland and wales
uh ruining new york for lots of them he
may save near for for the english really
if if we do still
see these figures plateauing as they are
it may show that just by being a bit
more delicate bit more flexible in
england than in scotland where they're
being very swift to to to to um to shut
things down i mean i looked i saw today
in scotland um the thing is there the
average um um the average day number of
omicron cases in england in scotland
sorry is up is up 50
um however the the number of scots in
hospital and intensive care both fell
today and that's the key point that
metric is supporting johnson at the
moment yeah i mean that's tricky isn't
it because there's been this big debate
about modeling this week um and some
scientists pushing back on it suggesting
that people are comparing the
non-intervention uh figures uh with full
intervention and actually it's been on
it's been an unfair argument this week
and certainly if if if this is this idea
of london peaking there's already
intervention isn't there by our own
behavior by working from home by the
circuit break that's come from school
see you know you can't really judge what
it would have been like if we'd carried
on as normal christopher i'm going to
come to you about this one so
you know what what figures exactly are
you waiting for
well what they want to see is actual
numbers in hospital intensive care
ticking up and that hasn't happened yet
now the big theory is that tired the
wave of cases going forward we know what
the forecast has been now for a couple
of weeks but we're just not seeing that
and i think you're right there anna that
people are they're listening to chris
whitty the the english uh
chief medical officer he said look you
know just just just roll back you know
if you're going to go out think who
you're seeing people are being careful
right now and cautious because they want
to see relations they want to see
elderly relatives on christmas day on
saturday and they're making their own
choices numbers in pubs bars and
restaurants they're down 50
sales are down 50 last weekend compared
to the same weekend in 2019. that's that
shows that people are listening to the
scientists and maybe that is helping too
but i agree it's difficult because you
don't know what may or may not have
happened in order
may affect the figures yeah the guardian
to the prime minister ruling out further
curbs on christmas socializing
the decision for england they point out
could lead to tougher rules in the new
year and the difficulty is how you you
measure the difficulties uh
we're in i suppose sonia one is the
severity hospitalizations length of time
of people staying in hospital the other
is staffing shortages especially in the
health service already people are being
told to get home quick for christmas
because trains aren't going to run a
full service so the the staffing issue
with these high levels 90 000 plus a day
is going to be a part of the factor
surely
absolutely i think you sort of put your
finger on it there um anna which is uh
um normally when we're talking about a
sort of covered wave it is really the
severity that we're looking at the
severity of the disease and the number
of hospitalizations and as i said
hospitalizations are going up in london
but not as fast as some people had had
feared so hopefully that's good news but
what a lot of health service leaders
have been warning about today is this
issue around staffing and absence and
that is really to do with a very very
high level of infection that we've got
at the moment so it's it's it's the
highest on record it's the highest it's
been during the pandemic and that really
means that it's starting to filter
through into
nhs staff who are off work or sick
having to self-isolate we're also seeing
it's not just an nhs issue but with
other emergency services so for example
over the weekend and last week
we saw
quite a few fire engines out of action
in london because there were so many
firefighters who were isolating we're
also seeing that with trains as you say
so what a lot of health staff are saying
is um we we need to keep an eye on both
things we need to keep an eye on the
number of staff who are off sick and we
need to keep an eye on increasing
hospitalizations because it could be
either of those things or a combination
of those things that really um creates a
critical crisis in the nhs where people
aren't able to get critical life-saving
care so hopefully we're some way off
that but i think it's interesting that
sanji javid has been talking about um
and it's in one of the papers today um
the idea that the time that you
self-isolate for is going to may go down
from ten days to seven days that would
probably really help but i think what
what um doctors will say is we need to
be really clear actually that the risks
that we're not increasing the risk of
people passing the infection on by
reducing that self-isolation time yeah
that's on the front page of the eye
actually uh uk health chiefs cut the
10-day isolation to seven days to help
workers shortages so that's that is
featured obviously in the newspapers but
let's talk about this politically i know
you spent a lot of time talking about
the cabinet for your reporting um
yesterday christopher uh just four
members of the cabinet who were more
supportive of this um
does do do we need to see higher figures
and more severity and more
hospitalizations for boris johnson to
get anything through for england given
the hundred mps given lord frost given
the cabinet you know some even
suggesting some are positioning in case
there's a leadership race you know they
need to see who their supporters were so
so do we need does it all need to be
much worse than it would have been if it
hadn't been difficult for the prime
minister
yeah that that's totally right anna i
mean i i'm expecting well from what i
was hearing a reporting on this the
parliament may be recalled next week to
look at further restrictions that's what
they're planning at the moment but
because the data is not clear and they
aren't sure if they're gonna that that's
required if that vote takes place
there's a real
risk for boris johnson if he's going too
far ahead of where the actual data is
he'll face another rebellion
and that could mean he has to get more
um this laws through next week on the
back of labor support the problem with
any pm who relied heavily on labour
support not his own mps or their own mps
uh doesn't last long if you look at
theresa may and brexit it soon ended
there and and the big the big i mean
many many people are expecting some
degree of challenge against boris
johnson unless he can refine his mojo
but that's a a different matter let's
get to omricon first but there is a lot
of people um who are concerned about him
on the tory back benches and that's why
he's he's moving forward cautiously i
mean he had the meeting yesterday we
thought there'd be a 5 pm press
conference didn't we yesterday afternoon
that never happened because it looks
like the cabinet said listen boris i
think you know we aren't yet seen the
figures here we have seen um overly fl
over inflated um forecasts in the past
let's see where this gets to but let's
be hyper aware of any changes in data
and that's where we are and i wonder
just wonder whether the pm maybe prove
right on this yes we'll come on to rishi
sunak's um
uh promises for for business in the
second half of our programme but
business does want certainty doesn't it
and certainly nicola sturgeon if we look
at the preston journal there uh you know
the blue january hog monday events
cancelled not good news for all of those
who would like to go for the money it
brings
to edinburgh and so on sonia but at
least there is some certainty
do you think we will get any
announcement before christmas about what
happens in england uh similar to wales
and scotland or or not
i i suspect not anna i think that um you
know the prime minister sort of saying
well that we're not going to have any
restrictions now um before christmas
um i i think he will be wanting to sort
of avoiding saying anything more about
this until just after christmas but it
could come very quickly just after
christmas and of course
i think it's really important to say
things can change very quickly and
omicron is spreading very very fast as i
was saying it does look like numbers may
be starting to plateau but you know that
may not hold true in the data over the
next couple of days so i think it's
really really difficult to predict
what's going to happen i think a lot of
people though will be worried in the
sense that you want to really feel at a
time like this that you've got a cabinet
and a prime minister who's very much
acting in the national interest
and i think that there are some people
who will be worried looking at this um
you know we've got a conservative party
that is in sort of chaos in disarray
we've got a really scandal rhythm prime
minister um with all these pictures that
have come out of christmas parties he
may not feel like he's got the authority
to do what he thinks needs to happen and
so i think that's why there may be a
level of nervousness in the country
about this is have we got a cabinet
who's taking the right decisions based
on some very uncertain data or have we
got some cabinet ministers who are
acting in their own political
self-interest okay uh christopher
there'll be plenty of time for you to
talk more about that i look at it
quizzically give me one sentence go on
then
well i'm not sure i think i think the
date is not certain and therefore the
policy isn't certain the risk is that i
think in wales and scotland they've used
uncertain data to be certain and that
could be a mistake okay
plenty more still to come on that and
other stories too businesses warn that
the financial support promised by the
chancellor will be nowhere near enough
to save them talk about that in just
[Music]
watching the press preview with me now
the chief leader writer at the observer
sonia soda and the chief political
correspondent at the delhi telegraph
christopher hope welcome back to both
the view
so rishi flew back and an announcement
today to help um struggling hospitality
and other business um will it be enough
do you think christopher or
is he on standby for more
it's not enough is it it's barely a
quarter of the way there if you ask a uk
hospitality which represents uh bars
clubs restaurants hotels in the uk they
wanted uh they've seen a fall of four
billion pounds in sales this is one
billion of you support it's barely a
quarter there as i say and the problem
is that people are just staying away
they're listening to what um the medics
are saying they're saying be careful
see be careful who you mix with because
you don't want to be in isolation for 12
days over christmas it'll be the the 12
days of miserable christmas no five goal
rings i mean crumbs why would you want
to do that so people are being quite
self interested here not going out as
much as they might do and that's really
hitting these uh the um the hospitality
sector so it's not enough but then it
never is my experience of this money
that that's offered up it never is
enough it's something and we which is
unique of course has done some work to
recover his equilibrium after being
caught out last week in los angeles
doing something over there not not sure
what on government business but doing
something over there meeting other
companies he flew back and has got
together um in about five days this
support package um it won't be enough
and it might might do something to help
these these different these companies
through difficult times yes and i think
the staying away really is about seeing
your older relatives at christmas for
for many people isn't it and you know
you you're trying to keep clean skinned
as it were but um the flight before
christmas has already started i did
wonder as i came in today and it seemed
quite busy whether working from home
allowed people to have a longer break
wherever they're heading sonia
yeah possibly um this story is really
about all the cancelled trains there's
quite a few train companies uh that have
announced really serious disruption lots
of cancelled services going out of
london up north to other parts of the
country
over this festive period and that is of
course because so many train staff are
off work sick recovered self-isolating
um it is all a bit worrying though isn't
it because as we know london is the
obviously people aren't just leaving
london there are trains between other
bits of the country but we know there
will be a lot of people leaving london
for christmas and london is the omicron
hotspot and those trains with so many
cancelled services are going to be even
more pat than usual um so i think there
will be a bit of concern about that and
obviously it's quite anxiety um inducing
if you're hoping to
get back to
where your family is for christmas or if
you're having to cross the country to
see family and you were relying on the
trains and your services have been
cancelled that's just really um that's
just really a bit a bit rubbish isn't it